For today, we're going to
be talking about autonomous
learning, specifically in
the context of reinforcement
learning for robots.
And this lecture
and the next lecture
are going to be focusing
a bit more on robotics use
cases, where today, we'll
be talking about autonomy.
And on Wednesday, we'll
be talking about--
we have a guest lecture talking
about sim to real transfer
and humanoid robots.
So we'll be talking about
why robots aren't autonomous
already, defining the problem
of autonomous reinforcement
learning.
And then developing
the algorithms,
specifically thinking
about learning policies
without human intervention,
and a formulation
of reinforcement learning
called single life reinforcement
learning.
So the goal here
will be to think
about how we can imbue
intelligent machines
with autonomy, the ability to
allow them to, on their own,
learn, interact,
practice, get better
without a human in the loop.
Cool.
So let's start with
some of the motivation.
So we've been talking a lot
about reinforcement learning.
We also talked a little bit
about imitation learning,
where imitation
learning, typically, we
are training an agent to
mimic some demonstrations that
are provided from an expert.
Whereas, in
reinforcement learning,
the agent is practicing
through trial and error.
And this notion of
practicing is something
that is already more
autonomous because the agent is
learning from its own
experience in the world.
But it actually isn't entirely
autonomous in practice,
when you think about
running these algorithms
on physical robots.
And in particular, if
we think about saying
that we want some robot that's
going from some initial state
distribution, some distribution
over initial states.
So this is the
starting conditions
that our agent
might be faced with,
when it's actually deployed
to some region of the state
space that has high reward.
Then, typically when we think
about this learning process,
we will collect trials.
So for example, maybe
at the beginning,
the first attempt at the
task will look something
like this, where because we
haven't learned anything yet,
maybe we haven't
practiced very much,
we don't have a trajectory
that is very good.
And then from there, typically,
we've thought about, OK,
can we retry the task and
attempt the task again,
where we, again, start from
a state in our initial state
distribution and rollout
our policy again.
Now when we're rolling
out these policies,
we are sampling actions
from our policy distribution
and acting according to
the agent's own actions.
And so each of
these trajectories
are under the control of
the robot or the agent.
And as you're rolling
out your policy,
this part is fully autonomous.
Control is fully
with the policy pi.
But one thing, one
little catch is
that after you've attempted
the task, once you're
in a state over here.
And we've been thinking
about when you then
attempt the task
again, magically,
you'll somehow
get back over here
and attempt the task
from this starting place.
And we haven't really
talked about how do you
get from here, all
the way back to here.
And in practice, when you
take traditional reinforcement
learning algorithms that
we've been talking about,
we've been assuming that a
human or, somehow, you'll
magically get reset to this
initial starting place.
And in practice, that might
mean that a human is actually
physically moving the
robot or physically
moving the objects
in the scene, back
to some set of
initial conditions.
And as a result, this process
isn't actually fully autonomous.
So on the slides, we'll execute
actions from our policy,
observe data from the
environment, update our policy,
repeat that process,
and eventually, we'll
get a policy that is
able to get high reward.
For example, in this
problem, reaching a state
within some region
of goal states.
And we think about
that as rolling out
some trajectory of length
h and then rolling out
another trajectory of
length h and so forth.
But we need to
think about, how do
we get from the end
of one trajectory
to the start of
another trajectory.
Now, if we're in a
simulation-based environment,
then what we can do is we
can create the environment,
take actions for a
thousand time steps.
And then once
we're done, then we
can call env.reset,
which is a very
nice little friendly utility.
But that's something that we can
only really do in simulation.
We can't reset the physical
world to our own will.
And so as some
specific examples,
say that you are trying to learn
how to navigate to a basketball
court.
Maybe you have a
small mobile robot
that is trying to deliver
something to the basketball
court, or an autonomous
vehicle that's
trying to navigate to
the basketball court.
As it tries to explore
and attempt this task,
it might make a wrong
turn, and rather,
if it makes that
wrong turn, it ends up
in that physical
location and would
need to, for example,
figure out how to navigate,
either back to the
starting position
or find its way from
that wrong turn,
back to where the
basketball truly is.
If we have a robot
manipulator, we
might want to learn
how to grasp the mug.
As we're learning
how to grasp the mug,
the robot might make a mistake
and knock the mug over.
And then, if it wants
to attempt and learn
how to grasp things
again, then, somehow, it
needs to be within
reach of the robot.
Or for more of a
mobile system, and we
want to learn how to put
books onto bookshelves, again,
we might make some
mistakes and need
to figure out how to get back
to some starting position, where
the book is in reach or some
initial state distribution,
if our goal is to go from
one set of initial states
to regions with high reward.
And one of the reasons why this
is actually especially important
is that reinforcement learning
often takes many attempts.
It's not a matter of
taking trying three times
and then solving the task.
Oftentimes, there's
many different trials
that you'll be attempting and
practicing over and over again.
And every time the
agent tries again,
that means that you have
some human intervention
or some other intervention
that is bringing you back
to the initial
state distribution.
As more of real examples,
this video on the left
is a video of a robot,
learning how to hit a hockey
puck into a goal.
And you can see that
the human here-- this
is a friend of mine,
Yevgen-- he's probably
doing more work than
the robot is right now,
as it attempts to do this.
Here's another
example, where Ali
is closing the doors
so that the robot can
learn how to open them.
And here's an
example where Archit,
who you gave a guest lecture
earlier this quarter,
is resetting the
robot so that it
can attempt to fold the towel.
OK, so how do we think
about this problem?
The problem is reset,
often in practice,
requires some
human intervention,
that we want to be able
to ideally eliminate
so that our agents can practice
and get better on their own,
rather than requiring
some expert or some human.
Now, one way that we
could look at this is--
I mean, what if we
could just increase h?
What if we just
increase the length
of the episodes in which our
agents are attempting the task?
And if we increase the length of
the episodes, then in principle,
we won't require as
much human supervision.
And we might be able to apply
the same exact reinforcement
learning algorithms that we've
learned about in the course,
just with less supervision
during the learning process.
So we can do that.
And so the we'll see an
example of what increasing age
looks like in a minute.
But generally, the definition
of what we want to accomplish
is initialize the
scene, the environment.
Maybe it's already
initialized in some way.
Then, we do that once.
We have the agent interact
autonomously with the world,
without any environment resets.
We could also relax this
constraint occasionally
to only reset at a
very low frequency.
For example, if h is very large.
Now, as we start to think
about these systems,
we need to think
about how we actually
want to evaluate these systems.
And there's actually a
couple different ways--
there's actually a
couple different things
that we might care about.
So one thing that
we might care about
is after, for
example, autonomously
learned in some environment,
we might care about--
maybe let's-- well, let's
say that we have autonomously
explored.
And for example, we have some
experience that we've collected.
Maybe that looks
something like this,
where there's no resets, no
going back to the initial state.
One thing that we might care
about is we might care about,
did you achieve high
reward as you went
about the agent's experience?
And basically, did it actually
complete the task at the end
of the day, as it was learning?
And that would be
looking at, what
is the sum of the rewards that
accomplished over its lifetime?
And alternatively,
instead of thinking
about evaluating autonomous
RL from that perspective,
we could think about after
the learning process,
did we learn a good policy that
we could then deploy and be
able to repeatedly do the task?
And so that would be looking
at if we-- instead of looking
at the rewards of
this red trajectory,
it would be saying after
the learning process,
if we've learned some
policy, how good is it at,
for example, going to the goal?
How good is the
policy that it learned
as an outcome of the
reinforcement learning process?
So two things here.
One could be the amount
of reward recovered
over the course of its life.
As one example of this, imagine
that you're deploying the Mars
Rover, and you want the
Rover to be able to collect
scientific data.
You don't really care about
whether it learned a good policy
that you're going to deploy
after the learning process.
You really care
about whether or not
it did a good job, as it was
deployed, as it was learning,
and so forth.
So that's more like
trying to measure how
good is this red trajectory.
And so here's my graphical
depiction of this on the slide.
Or you could learn about the
quality of the learn policy.
An example of this
is that if you're
learning how to
cook meals, maybe
there's some training process.
And you don't really
care that much about
during the training
process, how well it
was able to cook
as it was learning.
But then you really care about,
then can I deploy this system
and have it be able to cook
meals effectively, repeatedly
for a variety of
customers in the future.
Cool.
So that would be typical.
If we then took a policy that
we learned, initialized it
at the starting
state and ran it,
does it achieve good reward
under those conditions.
So we'll think about these
as two different things.
So we can-- first, let's
think about what we'll call
deployed policy evaluation.
So how good is the
policy that we learned,
if we were to then deploy it?
And the objective
for this circumstance
can be defined as an objective
that looks very similar to what
we've been seeing in
the course previously,
which is that you would sample
a state from your initial state
distribution and act
according to your policy
and measure the sum of rewards,
or the sum of discounted rewards
that was observed after
running an episode.
This should be an expectation
after starting from the state
and acting according
to the policy.
So this is deployed
policy evaluation.
How good is the policy if it's
starting from the initial state
distribution and acting
according to the policy?
Alternatively, if we
were to think about more
the continuing policy
evaluation, how good are,
if we just deploy the system,
and it's trying to learn,
as it goes, and how good is it
during that learning process.
Then we'd actually be
considering something
a little bit different.
We would want to
be considering what
is the average reward that
it saw during that learning
process.
And so we'd be looking at
something some average quantity.
So we'll write this as 1/h of
t equals 1 to h of the reward.
And if h is small,
this is not going
to be averaged
over small things.
And so we want to be
evaluating this, usually,
as our lifetime might be
getting longer and longer.
So this would be a
limit, evaluating
average reward and the limit
in which h goes to infinity.
So something like this.
And there should be an
expectation over this quantity.
Now, this expectation isn't
under a single policy.
It's over the learning
process itself.
So that's another
difference from measuring
how good a learned policy is.
Cool.
And so we'll look at algorithms
for both of these circumstances.
Yeah, so the question
is, why do we
need an expectation if we're
just running one trajectory?
If you want to evaluate,
just a single lifetime
or a single rollout of
your learning process,
then you could just
measure precisely that,
run it and see how well it does.
Now, in practice,
there's variability
that's caused by variability
in the environment,
variability in your
learning process,
like how you sample
batches and so forth.
And you may want to measure,
like at the algorithm level,
how good is your
algorithm at this problem?
And if you want to measure
how good the algorithm is,
you want an expectation over
multiple runs of the algorithm.
Why is this important?
We've already talked a
bit about the motivation,
but to elaborate on
a little bit more,
we want robots to operate with
minimal human supervision.
But we also want them to
train with minimal supervision
as well.
And generally, reinforcement
learning on real robots
is a promising path towards
achieving really high success
rates, really high reliability
compared to imitation learning.
And if you're able to train
with minimal human supervision,
then you're able to
collect more data,
and more data may also unlock
both greater reliability
and also greater generalization,
if these systems are
able to be deployed at scale
in a variety of real world
environments.
So that's the problem setup.
Now, let's dive a
bit into algorithms.
So we'd like to learn policies
without human supervision.
And we talked
about this question
before of, what if
we just increase
the length of the episode?
And can we just take
a traditional standard
reinforcement
learning algorithm?
In this case, I think we'll be
looking at a soft actor-critic
and just run it with longer
and longer episodes, which,
in principle, should require
less and less supervision.
If we do this, we see
performance changes a bit.
So this is a plot
that's evaluating
how good is the learned policy
after training for some number
of steps, shown on the x-axis.
So the y-axis is
reward, accomplished
by the deployed policy.
So it's measuring this
blue equation right here.
And this green line is if
you run with an episode
length of a thousand steps.
If you run SAC, you
get a learning curve,
where it's able to
learn a policy that's
able to effectively
complete the task.
Now, if you increase the
length of the episodes
during training
by a factor of 2,
we see that the
algorithm does worse,
and then we increase
it by a factor of 10.
We see that it does even worse.
And basically, as we increase
and make the episode length
longer, and as a result,
reduce the supervision required
for training, the
algorithm at the very end
is hardly able to learn
how to do the task at all,
how to learn a policy that
can do the task at all.
And I should mention this is
a very simple fish control
task, where your goal is to
navigate with what the fish can
do to a particular position.
So pretty simple task.
Even for the simple task, if
you increase your episode length
and don't give it
resets very frequently,
you're aren't able to
learn a good policy.
Now, why is this the case?
Does anyone have hypotheses for
why we're not getting a good
policy, if we only reset every
50,000 steps or 100,000 steps?
Yeah.
So the first issue that can
happen is it can make a mistake
and do something that's
bad, maybe leads it
to a part of the
state space that
is very hard to recover from.
In this particular
environment, I
don't think it's possible for it
to break its tail or something,
but you can basically
drift away from the state
distribution that's good.
And so if we were
to think about this,
maybe that diagram is
getting a little bit messy.
Our goal is to
learn a policy that
goes from some initial state
distribution to some goal,
as a simple reinforcement
learning problem.
As we're learning,
we might simply
deviate from where the
set of good states is.
And because of this
drift, it might
be very hard to
recover and get closer
to the parts that
have high reward.
So that's one challenge.
Does anyone else have
ideas on another challenge?
The other challenge is actually
a little bit more nuanced,
and in particular, say
that we drift away.
But maybe either in another
episode after one reset
or even for this episode, if
you are able to eventually get
to the goal, which is good.
You got reward.
From there, you might simply
stay in this region of the state
space.
And if you start
collecting a lot of data
in this part of the state space,
you're getting lots of reward.
And so the learning
process is great.
But then, if your goal
is to learn a policy that
starts from here
and goes to here,
you're not actually
visiting the states,
that will yield a good policy.
And so you might actually not
be visiting the states that
allow you to actually
go effectively from one
initial state to the goal.
So two challenges, if
we think about this rho
star as the optimal
state distribution
for getting from start to goal,
then in an episodic learning,
you can always retry the
task from the initial state
distribution.
Whereas, in autonomous learning
or non-episodic learning,
you'll continue from
where you left off,
and that exploration
might lead you
to drift away from the set
of good states for getting
to the goal.
And then even if you do
eventually get to the goal,
your state distribution
in your replay buffer
might collapse and might be
concentrated around the goal
rather than capturing the
state distribution that's
around the optimal policy.
And if you don't have states
from the optimal policy,
you won't know what to do
or what actions to take,
when you're in this
part of the state space.
Cool.
So as an outcome of
this, you'll never
actually learn a good policy.
So how can we learn
an effective policy?
So if the agent is allowed to
reset from the initial state
distribution, we do
learn successfully.
And so one very
simple idea is to try
to learn a policy that brings
us from wherever we ended up
after attempting the task
back to the initial state
distribution.
And we can call
this idea-- we can
think of this as a reset policy
or a backwards policy that's
trying to undo the task rather
than do the task forward.
And so we can think of this
as a forward backward RL,
because we will be learning
a forward policy that
does the task, and a backward
policy that undoes the task.
And where to put this?
Maybe let's do it over here.
So you'll first-- maybe step
0 is to initialize and sample
an initial state from your
initial state distribution,
basically initializing
the agent.
And then you're going
to repeatedly run
your forward policy,
which I'll call pi f,
then update your
forward policy by trying
to maximize the sum of rewards.
And this will be using
the reward function
for completing the task.
I'll call that rf, the
forward-reward function.
And then we'll reach some
state we won't reset,
and we'll run our
backward policy, pi b.
And then we can likewise
update our backward policy.
In this case, we
need to update it
for the reverse of
the forward task.
And so we'll actually rely
on a reward function that
will tell us if we are reaching
the initial state distribution.
And so this is going to
require a second reward
function, rb that is
going to serve as reward
for the backward policy.
Now in terms of
these update steps,
you can use your
favorite reinforcement
learning algorithm for this.
And critically, after we
run the backward policy,
we're not going to reset.
We'll then go back to running
the forward policy again.
And so what this
would look like is we
will define this
backward-reward function,
which is rewards us for reaching
states in the initial state
distribution.
Then we'll initialize
them and repeatedly
roll out the forward policy,
then update the forward policy,
with respect to
reaching the goal.
Roll out the backward
policy, which
is going to try to go back to
the initial state distribution,
then update the backward policy.
And then without
resetting, again,
try to roll out
the forward policy,
roll out the backward policy,
and repeat this process.
You can also have a reset very
infrequently, so occasionally
reset it, just in
case it does get stuck
in a really challenging state.
And then at test time, once
you're done with this process,
you can discard
the backward policy
and just deploy your
forward policy, which
should have learned,
ideally, how
to get efficiently from the
initial state distribution
to the goal, or
generally, to maximize
the forward-forward function.
One other small note here
is that we're going to be.
Typically, you need to
decide how long to roll out
the forward policy for.
The simplest thing
to do is simply
to roll it out for
h time steps, so
choose a constant number of
time steps to roll it out for.
You could imagine doing
something more sophisticated,
for example, before the forward
policy has learned anything,
the backward policy, if
it's not moving anywhere,
the backward policy
won't really have any job
to do at the beginning.
And so you, for
example, could run this
for a little bit longer
at the beginning,
but then at some
point, you also need
to run the backward policy
for a little bit longer.
And it's a bit simpler to just
use a fixed number of steps.
And ideally, if this
process is autonomous,
then the number of
time steps actually
matters a little
bit less because you
can go to sleep while your
robot is trying to learn.
Yeah, so the question is, is
there any information sharing
between the forward policy
and backward policy?
If you're using
replay buffers, you
could consider sharing
data between the two
and relabeling the rewards for
the forward policy for backward
policy, and vice-versa.
In practice, it's fairly
common to actually
not share much information.
You can also share an
image encoder, for example,
share some of the weights.
That can be helpful, but they
are actually trying to learn,
in some ways, very
different things.
And so that makes it
a little bit tricky.
We'll also see some algorithms
later on that do more sharing.
So the upside of this
algorithm is quite simple.
One of the downsides is
that this backward policy
that's trying to undo the task.
Ultimately, this is not
particularly useful.
So in some ways, it
seems a little bit
wasteful to learn
this policy, but it
does enable the autonomous
learning which is quite nice.
So this is the most
simple algorithm
you could use for trying
to learn autonomously.
But there are also some
alternatives that, in some ways,
have a number of
appealing properties.
So first, for your
backward policy,
you can actually change
the reward function
that it uses to actually
not reset all the way back
to the beginning,
but potentially
to reset from a larger
variety of states.
Second, we could, instead of
learning forward and backward,
just for one task,
we could think
about practicing a
cycle of different tasks
and not just learning a forward
task and a backward task.
We'll talk about that a bit.
And then the other
option is you can also
set up a task that can be done
repeatedly, where you can just
keep on attempting the
task over and over again
in certain special
circumstances.
And we'll talk about
that briefly as well.
Cool.
Let's first talk about
learning to reset
to a different initial
state distribution
from the initial state.
And so the motivation here is
that in forward-backward RL,
we're trying the task,
going back, trying the task,
going back.
And ultimately, we want
to be able to do complete
the task from the initial
state distribution,
but we also need
to know how to take
good actions, all along the
expert state distribution as
well.
And so one of the
things that we could do
is instead of going
back all the way
to the beginning,
every single time,
we could actually reset
to different states
along the expert
state distribution.
And there's actually
work that shows
that if you were to do this
and had a way to do this,
then you'd actually learn
a bit more efficiently
than always starting from the
initial state distribution,
even in episodic
learning settings.
And so the way that
this works is it's
basically going to be
the same exact thing
as before, but with basically
two small modifications.
And the first is that if we want
to be able to reset and learn
a policy that brings us to the
expert state distribution, then
we need a way to approximate
what that expert state
distribution is.
And so we'll assume that we
have a few demonstrations.
And so maybe negative 1
here is you're basically
given some set of expert
trajectories or expert
demonstrations, and
these will be examples
of ways to accomplish the task.
And then you need to
change the reward function
for the backward policy, where
the reward function shouldn't
be to reach the initial
state distribution,
but instead, it should
be to reach states
that the expert visits.
And so in particular,
we'll be given
a small set of demonstrations.
And ideally, what we want
this to look like is,
we'd run our forward policy.
And then when we run
our backward policy,
after it's learned
something reasonable,
ideally, it would
just bring us back
to the set of the set of states
in the expert distribution.
Then we run our
forward policy again,
and then it would
bring us back, again,
somewhere in this
pink region that
is showing the
distribution of states
that are visited by the expert.
And so the forward-backward
process is the same,
but we have this modified
backward-reward function.
And we're actually going to
learn this reward function.
And in particular, we
talked about in the lecture
on learning reward functions,
how you can train discriminators
to discriminate between
good states and bad states,
and use states from the policy
as examples of bad states.
And we can do the
same exact thing here,
where this reward function will
be trained to distinguish states
visited by the policy and states
visited in the demonstrations.
And then you'll be
trying to-- when
you're training the
backward policy,
you'll be trying to trick this
reward function into thinking
that it's the state
that's visiting
our states from the expert
and not from the policy.
And then, again, we'll
discard our backward policy,
when we're done, and
deploy our forward policy.
Cool.
So let's see some
demonstrations,
run our forward policy,
backward policy, and so forth.
This forward-backward RL
addresses the challenge
of preventing the agent
from drifting away.
And it also avoids collapsing
the distribution that we
talked about before as well.
Cool.
And then the upside that
I mentioned very briefly
is that if you try the task from
a wide set of initial states,
both easier states,
like states that
are closer to the goal
and further states, then
you could actually
improve the efficiency
of the entire reinforcement
learning algorithm.
The last thing that I'll
mention is that you can actually
use these demonstrations
in the replay buffers
as data to help train
the forward policy
and the reverse policy as well.
So the question is, if the
agent finishes the task,
does the backward
policy just stay there?
And here the answer is no.
So in the case of
forward-backward RL,
it would go back to
the initial state.
Whereas, in the case of
this MEDAL algorithm,
it'll try to push the policy
to a state in the expert state
distribution.
And specifically when we're
training the classifier
to classify between policy
states and expert states,
we're using all of the states
in the trajectories, all
the states in the demos.
And so it's going to, for
example, like in this graphic,
go back to somewhere over
here so that the policy then
learns and practices how
to do the task from here,
rather than only practicing
it from the goal state.
The question is,
what prevents it
from actually staying
in the goal state?
Because the goal state is
part of the demonstrations.
The specifics of--
I was thinking about
not going into this.
But basically, the specifics
of this reward function
is actually a state
distribution matching objective,
where it's goal is to match
the states that it visits
with the states and the demos.
And if it only resets
to the goal state,
then the classifier or the
discriminator of this reward
function will learn that if
you're only in the goal state,
then that's probably coming
from the policy and not
from the expert demos.
And it will be able
to distinguish that.
And the way that you can
formalize that is you
can actually think
about it as a divergence
between the
distribution of states
visited by the backward policy
and the distribution of states
visited by the experts.
Cool.
So let's actually briefly look
at how these algorithms perform.
So there's actually a
benchmark for this autonomous
reinforcement learning
setting called EARL.
And during training, you only
get a reset every 200,000
environment steps,
so very infrequently.
And the evaluation is,
how good is the policy,
when you start it from some
initial state distribution?
The benchmark has a
few different tasks.
This is probably
the simplest task
in the benchmark, where you
can basically try to grab a cup
and move it.
And there's this very
simple grabbing mechanism
that makes the task simpler.
And then we'll also look
at a more complex task
on the next slide.
And if we look at what
different algorithms do in this
environment, where they only
get resets every 200,000 steps--
First, if we just run SAC
without a backward policy, where
it only gets very
infrequent resets,
like we saw with the fish, the
performance isn't very good,
and it doesn't learn
a good forward policy.
If we use an Oracle that
is able to get resets
much more frequently
than it is actually
able to learn a good policy.
And then there's a few
reset-free algorithms.
One is something that tries
to perturb it, and encourage
it to visit novel states.
Another, showed in orange, is
the vanilla forward-backward
reinforcement
learning algorithm.
We can also give it
some goal curriculum.
I didn't talk specifically
about this algorithm.
And then the blue
algorithm is the algorithm
that's trying to reset back to
states in the demonstrations.
And so we see that, first, I
guess the main takeaway here
is that these algorithms that
are specifically designed
for this autonomous or
reset-free learning setting
are able to do much better
than if you don't design it
for that case.
And in this simple
environment, they all
perform fairly similarly.
And then as we move towards
more complex environments,
we see that forward-backward
RL and MEDAL
are able to do the best.
Whereas, simply,
if you instead try
to encourage it to visit
various states or goals,
those algorithms aren't
doing quite as well.
Yeah, the question is, we're
you assuming some expert
trajectories, how
are those generated?
So there's a variety of ways
that you can generate them.
On a real robot,
you would typically
use some teleoperation device.
And that could be using a
puppeteering-like setup or a VR
controller or a 3D
mouse or a keyboard.
In simulation, it can
either be something
that's like a scripted policy
that is designed by a person,
or it could be a policy that's
trained with RL ahead of time,
just to test the algorithms.
Can I describe what
the episodic part is?
So episodic is a term
that often refers
to the traditional
reinforcement learning
setting, where we
can attempt the task,
and reset and attempt
the task again,
where each attempt
is like an episode.
And so it's very episodic.
You get one episode.
You try again, you
get another episode.
And then it's not the best
term, but that's one term,
and then non-episodic
refers to the setting
where you don't
get those resets.
You just let it go.
And so it's no longer
a bunch of episodes.
It's just like one
long learning process.
Sometimes, that
learning process is also
called reset-free because there
are no resets in the process.
Oh, the other thing that I
should mention, actually,
that's cool about
this particular task
is the forward task
is to close the door,
and the backward task
is to open the door.
And the backward
task is, actually,
depending on where
the arm starts,
it can actually be quite a bit
harder than the forward task.
And so you could, sometimes,
have these mismatches
between how hard it is
to do the forward task
and how hard it is to
do the backward task.
And that can make these
algorithms-- that can generally,
sometimes, make the learning
process a bit more challenging.
Because the forward
policy, the backward policy
will learn at different rates.
Similarly, if you
could imagine--
if your forward task
is to do a backflip,
for example, maybe doing a
backflip is really challenging,
but getting up and standing
up to start doing the backflip
is comparably easier.
And so it's fairly
common to have
a mismatch in that difficulty.
These algorithms have also--
you can actually run them on
real robots, and it's cool.
You can watch time
lapses of them.
The left video is running
forward-backward RL,
where it's learning
a forward policy,
learning a backward policy.
And you can see that both
policies make mistakes,
and it's able to--
I don't know if you can
see it in the context
of this single video, but
it is able to improve just
through a fully
autonomous process.
And then the right is
the metal algorithm.
And you can see
that, for example,
if the forward policy misses,
then the backward policy
doesn't really have much to do.
And so you do see, yeah,
that another property
of the algorithm in the video.
Cool.
One other thing
that I'll mention
is that rewards are also
something that provide.
And so using reward
learning algorithms
in conjunction with autonomous
or reset-free algorithms
is also quite common, and in
both of these circumstances,
the rewards were using models
rather than using humans.
So that this entire
process can be autonomous,
and you can actually run
it overnight, for example.
Yeah, so the
question is, it seems
like for some of
these tasks, if you
don't have a good
backward policy,
then it's really hard to
learn the forward policy.
And also, vice-versa,
if you don't
have a good forward
policy, then you're
never actually going to
be picking up the towel.
And then you need to
figure out how to--
then you're not really getting
actually any good states.
In general, one of
the things you can do
is, you can provide
demonstrations,
both for the forward task
and for the backward task,
and use that to help
bootstrap the learning process
for both of them.
Other than that, it
is just generally
a challenge and to try to
balance these two things.
Yeah, in general,
the algorithms are
able to work in some settings.
I should also mention
that these works--
most that are doing
these, they're still--
I mean, certainly, still in
the research stages, I think.
This is not something that
robot companies are using today.
Yeah.
Cool.
So we've talked
about algorithms that
learn a reset policy to help
learning a forward policy.
Now, we can also think about
a slightly different setting,
which is that if we're trying
to learn, not just one task,
but multiple tasks,
then we could actually
think about not just going
forward and backward,
but practicing going in cycles
and practicing different tasks,
depending on what
state you're in.
So for example, if
you have a robot
that's trying to make coffee,
maybe the first task is to put--
or the first subtask is to put
the cup in the coffee machine.
And maybe if it attempts
that, it actually
drops the cup on accident.
And then, traditionally,
what you would do
is you would have a
human reset the cup back
to where it started.
But we don't want to do that.
And so, instead,
maybe the second task
is instead of-- because
it made a mistake,
the second task shouldn't be
to turn on the coffee machine.
Instead, it should be
to pick up the cup.
And so we can imagine having
these different cycles,
where we practice task 1.
Then if we fail,
we practice task 2.
And then task 2 maybe
is resetting task 1.
We maybe then go
back to task 1, which
is to put the cup in
the coffee machine.
If we didn't succeed at task
2, we might keep trying it.
If we do succeed at task 1 at
putting the coffee machine,
we might move to task 3,
and so on, and so forth.
And so we can have this graph
or cycle of different tasks
that we're trying, at
different points in time,
depending on the state we're in.
We'll practice a
different task that
is possible to practice
from that state
and exclude tasks that are
not feasible from that state.
Cool.
So what this would
look like is, we
will be learning a task
condition policy, so
like a multi-task policy.
And we will be in some state,
and so we'll observe the state
that we're in.
And then based on the
state that we're in,
we'll propose a
task that we want
to practice from that state.
So we'll have a step
that is proposing
a task that we can use Zi to
denote the task that we're
proposing.
And this could be the
descriptor for that task.
And then we will run the
policy for that task.
And so this could be
a multi-task policy
that's conditioned on Zi.
And then we could also
have an update step,
where we update our policy.
If we have more
on-policy algorithm,
then this would be updating
it for this particular task.
If we have an
off-policy algorithm,
we could update it
for any of the tasks,
and then repeat
this process, where
after we've run it for that
task for some number of steps,
we'll then propose a different
task and practice that task.
So initialize our
policy, propose a task,
roll out the policy for
each steps, and then update.
And specifically,
we'll be updating it
with the reward function that
takes into account the tasks
that we're practicing.
So we'll need a reward
function for all of the tasks
that we might be doing.
Yeah.
And then, again, we
won't have resets,
or we'll have a very
infrequent reset.
And then, at test
time, we can then
deploy this multitask policy,
which can do not just one task,
but multiple different tasks.
And as an example, this
is a robot system that
is the goal is to pick up--
basically, it's different
stages and different tasks
or different stages.
You want to pick up this object,
flip it over, and rotate it.
And there are different
subtasks here.
And so at the beginning, it
doesn't know how to flip it,
and it doesn't certainly
doesn't know how to rotate it.
Or maybe it does actually
know how to flip it,
but it isn't very
good at rotating it.
It's something where,
at the beginning,
you don't know how to
flip it or rotate it,
and you'll basically just be
like practicing picking it up
from the hand and putting it
back, picking it up, putting it
down, put it down.
And then once you get
better at picking it up,
then you'll start to
actually rotate it or flip it
over and rotate it.
And so depending on which
state you're actually in you'll
actually practice
something that makes
sense for that given state.
And this can actually address
some of the challenges
that we talked about with regard
to imbalance and tasks, where
if you haven't actually
yet successfully run
the forward policy to
actually change the state.
And you may not
even be in a state
where it makes sense to
run the backward policy,
then you can keep on running
the policy for a task that
makes sense.
As a couple examples--
more examples
of this, this
example on the left,
you're trying to learn both
for walking forward and walking
backwards.
And you also, at the
same time, are actually
learning how to get back up.
And so you can see it kind of
transitioning between going
forward, going backward.
If it's too far to
the back, then it
will doesn't want to
keep on going backwards,
and so then you'll practice
the task of going forwards.
And likewise, this example on
the right, there's actually
it's like a
seven-stage test, where
you need to pick it up, position
it, and screw repeatedly.
And so it's running
these different policies
or these different controllers
based on the state that it's in.
And eventually, it will also run
the backward policy of putting
the wrench back on the table.
Yeah.
So the question is, how do we
select these tasks, basically?
Yeah, basically, there
are two approaches
that have been done here.
And this is also at the bleeding
edge of research in some ways.
The verses that you could
predefine a set of tasks
and also predefine that graph,
saying if you failed task 1,
then you should go
should practice task 2.
And basically,
upfront, predefine
that graph of what you should
do in different circumstances,
and then act according
to that graph.
Alternatively, you could
also train a model that
proposes tasks for you to do.
And so, for example,
in general, I
think it's an open question,
with regard to which tasks
you pick to collect for
at a given point in time.
But you could, for example,
ask a language model to say,
what are the different
things that I could
do in this environment to
get better and actually
then practice the tasks
that it describes as output.
And so as an example
of that, if we are at--
if this is the
frame that we're in,
then there's certain things
that we can do in this task.
We could open this
toy microwave.
We could pick up the banana.
We could push the
eggplant, move the pot.
But if we instead told
it to pick up the carrot,
that's not something that
you can do in the scene.
And if we're trying
to actually train
it to do lots of
different things,
these tasks are going
to be seen dependent.
So then you could ask
a VLM to understand--
think about what are
the things that you
can do in this environment,
and then have it predict,
for example, take the banana
out of the silver pot.
And then from there,
actually, have
it practice doing this
task versus practicing
doing some other task.
The question is, how
is this different
from hierarchical learning?
So it's a good question.
So this task proposer,
you can think of it--
it shares some similarities with
the high-level policy that's
telling you what to do in
a certain circumstance.
But its purpose is
actually quite different.
So the purpose here is actually
having it propose things
that you could do
in the environment
that you could practice.
Whereas, in a
hierarchical system,
the high-level policy
goal is to say like,
what is the next subtask that
will achieve some outcome
at the end of the day?
And so this is
actually something
where you want it to give
you lots of different things
that allow you to learn
lots of different things.
Whereas, a high-level
policy, you're much more
goal directed in
terms of accomplishing
some long-term objective.
This particular work
chooses to actually use
a hierarchical method.
It's actually builds
upon one of the works
that we talked about previously,
where it actually then feeds
this into an image
editing diffusion model
to generate an image
of a generated goal.
And then it trains the policy
to try to reach this goal image.
And one of the things
that's nice about this
is that with this
approach, you need
to update this, using a
reward function for each task.
And it can be quite challenging
to define a reward function
for all of the different tasks.
Whereas, if you have
an image of the task
that you're trying
to accomplish,
then your reward function can
be based on whether or not
you're close to this image.
And so it makes it easier to
define the reward functions.
Your question is, would this
proposer give those outputs?
Yeah.
So, absolutely.
So this framework was applied
to these simple robot scenes.
But you could also, for example,
like in the hockey example,
ask it, like, what
are the things
I could do in this situation?
Should I practice passing?
Should I practice shooting?
For those particular
examples, I think
it's also reasonable
to just-- there's only
limited number of things
that you need to practice,
and so you could just have one
session on practicing goals,
one session on passing.
But, yeah, you could also
use an idea like this
to actually propose what to try
to do in different situations.
Those are a couple of
autonomous learning algorithms,
the first category
being algorithms,
where you try to do
the task, and then
undo the task in various ways.
The second, where you're
trying to then try
to do one task and then another
task, and then another task,
and try to just get better
at lots of different tasks
all at once.
There's also actually
some scenarios,
where you can actually
set up the task in a way
that you can do it repeatedly.
And there isn't
necessarily a lot
of research on this
particular idea,
but in this particular
example, the goal
is to fold napkins for
businesses, where you
need to fold lots of napkins.
So those are all circumstances,
where we want to learn a policy.
And like our goal is to get a
good policy rather than simply
the Mars Rover example, where
we want to maximize rewards.
There's also the second
category of problems,
and the motivation is that we've
been trying to learn policies
without resets.
You'd improve the
quality of the policy
through practice, but
then at some point,
we're actually going to
be deploying the policy.
And ideally, this policy
will be pretty good.
And maybe you're in a scenario
where, obviously, everything's
going to work perfectly.
Nothing will ever go wrong,
when you actually go and deploy
your policy.
But in practice,
that's not the case.
And the natural world,
things will go wrong,
despite having a
lot of training.
And this latter setting
is thinking about,
after we've learned
some sort of policy,
when it's out in the
world on its own,
can it recover from mistakes
and learn after the deployment
process?
And this is something that
even humans do to some extent.
So here's a video where a
person is trying to open a door.
And if you look
really carefully,
you'll notice that, actually,
the person makes a mistake,
and then adapts, really,
in a split second in order
to accomplish the task.
So if you play this
video again, we'll
see that right here, the person
is trying to apply force,
and the key actually isn't
correctly in the hole.
And then they try again by
removing the key backwards,
and then putting it
back into the keyhole.
And there's lots of examples
like this, hopefully,
that you've encountered in
your own deployed policy.
And we'd like to think
about this setting, where
we could actually adapt, within
an episode, during deployment.
So in terms of how this
compares to previous algorithms,
we've talked about--
a lot of the course
has been talking
about this episodic setting,
where you attempt it
from the initial
state repeatedly
and then deploy the policy once.
We also talked today about
this reset-free setting,
where you learn how
to attempt the task,
undo the task repeatedly, and
then want to deploy your policy.
And this more recent setting
is something where you
have some prior training data.
Maybe you've trained
a policy, and you're
in some new out-of-distribution
circumstance.
And as you're trying to actually
do the task, because you're
in some new circumstances, you
need to do some problem solving
and actually adapt and
learn during deployment,
during a single
episode without resets.
And so you can think of
this as after previous data
or previous training, you
have one life to autonomously
complete the task.
As a fairly simple
example, maybe you
have training
experience in a flat,
like running in
like flat ground.
And then at some point,
you encounter some obstacle
that you hadn't
seen before, and you
need to figure out how to
get over this obstacle,
despite not having seen
this during training.
And you want to use
reinforcement learning
or use some ideas
from reinforcement
learning to adapt to
the new circumstances,
live within an episode.
So one thing we might think
about is, can we just run--
can we continue to fine tune
our policy with reinforcement
learning at test time?
If, for example,
we make a mistake,
maybe we can just
update our policy
with TD updates or
policy gradients,
live, as we're rolling
out our policy.
And so if we actually do
that-- so we train a policy
and then try to fine tune it at
test time with this obstacle,
we get something
that looks like this.
So the policy actually
does figure out
how to get over
the first obstacle,
even though it has never
seen that obstacle before.
And then, eventually,
it actually
gets stuck on flipped over.
And even though it's running
reinforcement learning,
and you can see it's--
it is somewhat trying to get up.
It essentially gets stuck.
And even though you're
still running reinforcement
learning, still
running the policy,
and still running
updates, it isn't
able to recover
from these states
that it hasn't seen
before, without on its own,
without interventions.
And ideally, we'd have a
policy that could figure out
how to get up and how to
retry during deployment
in these new circumstances.
Now this is also
something that's
bleeding edge of research.
And I'll just mention a few
ideas that have been proposed,
that seem to be quite helpful
for addressing this problem.
One is that when you're getting
stuck, you end up in this state
that it's hard to recover from.
And if you're doing
reinforcement learning updates,
say that you are
running your policy,
and somehow, you get
stuck right here.
If you're running
reinforcement learning updates,
you are running reinforcement
learning updates,
with regard to the task
of getting to the goal.
And if instead of trying to run
RL updates to get to the goal,
if you instead tried to run RL
updates to get back to states
that are familiar, like
good states that you visited
in your previous
experience, then
you might have a better
time at getting unstuck,
where, for example,
these states might
be closer to the ones
that are at the goal
and help perturb the agent back
to something that it knows.
So that it could then
continue doing the task.
So that's one idea.
And then another idea is to
try to leverage pre-training.
So if you're trying to
run reinforcement learning
on the policy weights, like
in the low-level action space,
you can only change
the policy so much.
And there's only so
many ways you can adapt.
And if instead, if you could
adapt in a higher level
space, if you had some
set of pre-trained skills,
then you might be able to
actually adapt more drastically
and actually try to change a
strategy that you're taking,
rather than just changing
the weights or the actions
that you're using.
So, for example, if you learned
a skill for a pre-trained skill
for walking forward
and a pre-trained skill
for getting back on your
feet, then instead of trying
to continue walk forward
in that new state,
if you tried to explore the
different skills that you have
and explore the state
of getting back up,
then you might be
able to actually
be more successful at
handling these circumstances.
Because you're basically able to
try different strategies rather
than just trying different
actions or different weights.
The other thing here is
that pre-trained LLMs
might have some common
sense reasoning that
could allow an agent to adapt
a novel circumstances as well,
and try different strategies.
So let's look at
a couple examples
of these ideas in practice.
So if we take the
first idea that's
trying to guide the agent
with reinforcement learning
to familiar states
rather than to the goal,
we can actually run it
on that same example.
And we see that the
agent does actually--
I mean, this is still an
out-of-distribution environment.
It does get stuck on its back,
but it is able to, for example,
get back up after trying.
So here, it's stuck
on its back, and it's
trying to get back to a
state that's familiar,
for example, a state
where it's on its feet.
And it's able to
eventually recover
from that after
a bit of attempts
and then make it
to the goal state.
And then in terms
of adapting, we
talked about adopting
the low-level space
and in the high-level space.
This first example
is a system that
was trained to be able to
adapt in the low-level space
from recent history.
And this is able to handle
some small out-of-distribution
scenarios, where it's like
on different terrains.
But if you have things
that are more drastically
different from what
you've seen before,
it can be very helpful to adapt
in a more high-level space.
And so what that could
look like is say that you--
say that you have this
legged robot that's trying
to reach a goal over here.
Then, if for example,
all the agencies
is this image right here
tries to go forward,
goes backward, if you
just keep on running
a policy without any
context, it'll just
keep on trying to go forward.
Because it doesn't know that
it tried going forward before.
If instead you try
different strategies
like moving left, moving
backwards, with context
and adaptation, then you can
figure out how to, ultimately--
Even though the agent
in this particular case
has never seen this environment
before, it's able to problem
solve its way through
these different obstacles
and navigating to
a goal position.
This is something where if you
adapt it in the low-level motor
space, trying out different
positions of your joints, then
it would be very tricky
to try to problem solve
through this circumstance.
Cool.
So that was a brief foray into
this single-life reinforcement
learning setting.
Yeah, good question.
So how do we bake in
safety constraints?
So yeah, another
circumstance that
might require human oversight
is, if you're in scenarios,
where you could make safety
critical mistakes-- if you
are a legged robot, you can fall
in a way that damages the robot.
If you're a manipulator,
you could drop a glass
onto the floor.
You could also hit
objects pretty hard.
There's actually work
that builds very directly
upon some of these
ideas, where you actually
try to learn some
notion of safety
and learn when you're
actually in a high risk state,
and then go back to a
state that is less risky.
So you could actually learn, for
example, a recovery policy that
tries to get back to
states that are known
to be less risky and more safe.
And so these ideas,
actually-- some of these ideas
were actually, several years
ago, studied in safety settings.
The other practical
thing to do is
to try to, to the
extent possible,
try to impose safety
constraints on the controller
itself so that,
for example, you're
not using the motors to the
point in which they'll overheat
or minimize, have a box around
the robot that doesn't allow it
to, for example,
apply a lot of force
to different parts
of the state space.
Now, that's not
possible everywhere.
And learning notions of
safety might be the only way
to actually address
the problem in general.
Although to learn safety,
you need examples of failing.
So it's generally a
pretty tricky problem.
And yeah, I guess those are
my main thoughts on that.
Yeah, so you also--
the question is maybe
when navigate around
people, you could
try to ask a VLM,
like what you might
try to do at a high level
in different circumstances.
And this work, right
here, actually,
was using a VLM to indicate
with past experience what
are good strategies to try.
And so these models may have
some common sense, suggesting
maybe you shouldn't walk or
run into a person, for example.
Or maybe you should
wait, that sort of thing.
And so leveraging those
common sense in those models
is fairly promising.
Cool.
Great.
So to summarize, we talked
about why reinforcement learning
algorithms don't already
give robots autonomous
learning capabilities.
And define the problem,
define a couple instances
of this problem,
where we either want
to think about the lifetime
of rewards or learning
a good policy.
And we talked about
algorithms for each
of those, where we
try to, for example,
learn a backward policy,
learn a task graph,
and try different tasks,
and also single life
RL to prevent drift.